okay hey everyone it's Mike valos here
from waterf flows.com and today I'll be
talking about my new indicator the wos
transition this is the third indicator
that I've released recently um the other
two was the flip and the U-turn and you
know I was putting them together as as a
three-part package and you know people
were complaining they were saying oh you
know it's terrible but you know what
they didn't take the time to actually
sit down and learn it and you know I'm
creating these videos so that you can
see how it's used and you know examples
you know for the entire month of January
on many different contracts you know
with proper settings um you know I I
have a feeling people were buying this
indicator and just throwing it on their
chart willy-nilly you know without
adjusting any settings and just using a
default setting for every single thing
they're trading and you know not reading
not taking the time to read the
instructions you know it boggles my mind
you know people will spend hundreds and
even thousands of dollars on on trading
software and not take 15 minutes to go
through a user manual um you know and
then and then then they wonder why
they're they're losing money trading um
you know I mean it's it's I I just don't
understand it but um you know I mean
hopefully you know by watching this
video this will explain it more in depth
that you can you know get some value out
of it so yeah out of the three recent
ones the transition the BOS transition
it's actually one of my personal
favorite indicators that I had
programmed and my indicators what they
do you know they're not necessarily
supposed to be Black Box take every
single uh signal as it occurs you know
go to the bank like that it's makes
orderflow analysis easier and you know
that's that's what an indicator should
do is it should relieve some of the
analysis from you and you know do it for
you and you know for a lot of Traders
looking at an orderflow chart is boring
there's a lot of numbers colors zones
Etc but honestly that information is
gold you know if you know how to analyze
it
you know but first you know in in
trading you know the markets they
started out with you know bar charts you
know simple open high low close and you
know then came candlesticks you know
people say well candlesticks were around
for 300 years but you know in Western
forms of analysis is really the bar
chart came first and then you know the
Candlestick charts were introduced to
westerners uh commercially back in the
back in the 80s you know even though you
know there were people that were looking
at them back in the 30s but you know for
for all intensive purposes you know they
they really became popular back in the
1980s and you know around the turn of
the century the turn of the century um
you know the early 2000s the footprint
chart came into popularity and you know
so you're making this big change from
you know just open high low close to you
know even colors in your chart with you
know if it opens and closes higher than
where it opened you know it's it's green
if it Clos lower than where it opened
it's it's red you know people are visual
um you know that if if you look at all
these popular social media sites you
know Pinterest
Instagram you know they're just it's all
images and you know being able to get a
good snapshot of what is happening in
the market you know via an image I think
you know people can process the the data
better so you know think of it this way
you know what's what's you know which
chart is better to look at a bar chart a
Candlestick chart or a footprint chart
well you know look at yourself in the
mirror when you're sick right you know
you're sick but you know you don't know
what's wrong with you so you take your
temperature okay you have a fever you
have a high temperature okay that's
progress but to really understand what's
wrong with you you know you'll go see a
doctor you know maybe get an x-ray
that's what the orderflow chart is it's
going to the doctor and getting that
x-ray so you can see exactly what's
wrong with you you know a doctor can't
necessarily diagnose what's wrong with
you just by looking at you you know he's
going to want to take your temperature
poke you with some needles maybe you
know take a blood test you know and get
an x-ray you know cuz he wants to know
what's what's going on inside that's you
know making you
sick so you know before I get started
you just go through a brief disclaimer
um for uh legal purposes this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures train contains substantial risk
and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results you the cftc rules uh especially
4.41 State hypothetical or simulated
performance results have certain
limitations unlike an actual performance
record simulated results do not present
actual trading and since the trades have
not been executed the results may have
under or over compensated for the impact
if any of certain Market factors such as
lack of liquidity simulated trading
programs in general are also subject to
the fact that they are designed with the
benefit of hindsight no representation
is being made that any account will or
is likely to achieve profit or losses
similar to those
sown and you know there's a reason why
you know the the
cftc and which is bit you know sometimes
I think is a bit overbearing on the
industry but there's a reason why they
they have that disclaimer is because you
know people tend to think that
everything is going to be 100% accurate
and you know they're going to buy a
trading indicator and it's just going to
be you know hey free money you know
picking up gold nuggets in in the street
but it's it's really not you know if you
think that orderflow will give you every
Market Turning Point with 100% accuracy
or guarantees the timing of of your
entries and exits you're sortly mistaken
you know it can point you in directions
you know when the Market's making them
turn but it's not going to give you
necessarily every single turn you know
honestly nothing can you know there's
I'm not a believer in the random walk
Theory you know where you know there's
just pure Randomness into the market
because there are times when you can
clearly see changes in the
market and you know orderflow represents
the everchanging market environment and
what this indicator Vol transition does
is becomes a visual representation of
the more subtle forces at work supply
and demand momentum and public
perception about price of the
market so what moves the market okay I
mean it's basic right supply and demand
is you if if you ask a 100 people hey
what moves the market and most people
will say supply and demand okay that's
obvious but if you're looking at a
normal bar chart how can you determine
supply and demand I mean really be let's
be honest here you know if you go back
to you know this chart here how can you
tell what supply and demand what's going
on in the supply and demand you really
can't but when you look at an order
flows chart you can see the volume
that's being traded in certain areas you
know if if price is being defended or if
price is being rejected you know those
are all signs of supply and
demand now you know you as a Trader
right
you have to develop skills and knowledge
to recognize changes in Market sentiment
you know a Trader will never achieve
100% total accuracy in Market timing but
rather what you want to do as a Trader
right is you want
to increase the frequency of possible
profitable trades and reduce the number
of losing trades so again you know
you're never going to be 100% right
anybody that claims it is you know is
basically lying to you I mean there's no
other way to say it but um you know what
you should be doing as a Trader is you
know honing your skills to recognize
changes in in the market
sentiment so you know this is an
orderflow chart and you know for a lot
of people it's you know it really makes
no sense especially the first time they
look at it but you know to an
experienced orderflow Trader you it
makes perfect sense you can see that the
market is bottoming here and you can be
fairly confident in getting long off
this low you know in in here so where
you know anywhere down in here an order
full trador would be looking to be
getting
along but you know not
everybody has that experience or you
know has that skill or or even even that
knowledge and you know what that's why I
create these indicators because you know
I take my knowledge you know I've got
extensive knowledge in trading
especially with orderflow that you know
to me it's second nature to look at a
chart like that and and see what's going
on but for a lot of people it's
difficult you know it's going to take
years I mean you know these people say
oh you know to become proficient in any
trade you got to spend 10,000 hours well
honestly you know if someone told
me that you know I have to be become
proficient now in trading I got sit in
front of a screen for 10,000
hours I I'd say forget it you know I'm
not going to spend 10,000 hours of my
life sitting in front of a trading
screen hoping to you know get that
knowledge you know I was fortunate I did
spend that time but but that was my
career that's what I did to pay my bills
and you know if if I didn't pick it up
quickly I I'd be working in a grocery
store the rest of my life or something
and you know so people say oh you have
to have 10,000 hours uh to be successful
at it you know to really understand it
no you don't okay and you know if if you
can't pick up
trading relatively quick you know then
you got to use tools that are going to
help you understand what's happening in
the
market and another reason why
you know I create these
tools is for my own for my own trading
and you know sometimes I miss trades
because I'm not paying attention you
know I could be checking my phone I
could be surfing the internet or
whatever and you know it could be just
now you know I just had a sip of water
you know sometimes you take your eye off
a screen and you miss something and you
know what these indicators are designed
to do is point out when conditions in
the order flow meet certain
requirements and you know the beauty of
them is you know I've had than program
so you don't necessarily need to look at
an orderflow chart it will run on a bar
chart so you know personally I think you
get most value out of looking at an
orderflow chart but again you know I
know some people are just intimidated by
the orderflow chart and they would
rather stick to a bar chart because you
know that's what they use you know fair
enough and you know this is a tool that
I think you can put on your chart that
will help you you know this is this is
today this is what's today February 10th
okay this is the euro currency 6E March
contract 1 minute
chart you know basically from 7:30 until
almost 2:00 and you there was three
signals there was a buy Here a sell here
a sell here okay so you know when when
people get these indicators and
literally they come back to me I've had
one I had one guy buy it sign up for it
at gosh I think at around 5:00 a.m. and
at noon so it's not even 6 hours come
back to me complaining you know saying
oh it's terrible and you know I just
shaking my head and then I try to ask
him you know what are you looking at you
know time frame you know let me help you
and you know he wasn't you know he
didn't care he didn't want to share say
hey I'm looking at this contract in this
time period you know with these settings
you know it's just a this is the worst
thing ever you know and it just kills me
because you know people don't want to
take the time to you know learn this you
I put out other videos of this you know
showing how effective this indicator is
and for whatever reason people don't
want to take the extra 5 minutes to you
know change you it doesn't take 5
minutes it takes 10 seconds to change
the settings or at least take 5 minutes
to you know reach out to me send me an
email saying hey you know these are the
markets I'm looking at you know with the
setting with this time
frame should I be looking at something
else okay fair enough you know honestly
though I had one guy come back to me
he's looking at 15 minute charts 30
minute charts and I said okay okay you
know right off that as soon as he said
that I said well it's probably not going
to be very effective you know I was I'm
being honest and I'm not trying to just
go out there and get everybody's money
but if I don't think it's going to be
effective in the way that you're trading
yeah then then you know you don't need
it um but you know if you're trading in
the shorter term you know intraday which
a lot of people are then you know this
tool will be very effective like I said
this is one of my favorite ones actually
you know it's like having these
indicators it's like having kids
sometimes you know I don't want to say I
have favorites but um you know I got
three kids and I probably spoil my
daughter the most although I spoil them
all but um I I I noticed that when I do
shopping for things for them generally
it's uh the girl that comes out ahead
even my wife gets angry at me sometimes
cuz I don't get stuff for her but anyway
so one of the reasons getting back to
the reasons why I create these
indicators is you know because the
problem many Traders face and I'm guilty
of it sometimes
knowing how to interpret a single a
signal is is never easy you I might find
myself looking for a trade when there is
none you know sometimes the market is
just
slow and you know and I really am kind
I'll say anxious but you know what I can
sort of read a little bit more into you
know something that that's not
necessarily there and especially you
know if the Market's going sideways and
you know so having an indicator you know
that sort of meets a minimum requirement
for me and in terms of you know volume
activity and and what's happening in the
markets then you know it will it will
help me um you know find more trades
because I could watch more markets
rather than sit there try and stare at
20 again I don't say go out and trade 20
different markets honestly I've got
about four markets on my screen at any
given moment that I'm concentrating on
but you know because honestly it's it's
if you're just watching One Market you
know there there's people they have
these ideas like oh one you know you got
to just learn One Market learn it inside
and
out everything that's about that one
market and you'll be successful no no
because there's going to be times when
you know that one market is just dead
and when I say dead I mean you know it
could be quiet for for many months you
know corn is is a perfect example there
there's times of the year when corn is
very active there's times of the year
when corn is watching paint try you know
you have a 4 Cent range all day and you
know how you going to make make any
money you got to move to other contracts
you know that's how you know back in the
days when there was the pits the trading
pits you know people would venture when
one when one pit was quiet but another
pit was active you know the guys in the
pit that was quiet would well they
realize there's not going to be any um
you know chances are there's not going
to be any action here today and they
would walk over to the pit that was
active and and try and get involved and
you know sometimes that's what you got
to do when when you're
trading so so what I did was you know I
took my strongest methods of order flow
analysis you know I've I've got a a few
quite a few but you know I found I
realize you know when I go over the
trades that there's certain ones that
you know appear more
frequently and that are generally more
profitable than than others so you know
I've been in the process of getting them
programmed over the last couple years
and you know this is the latest you know
it's the Vols transition and it looks
for times when the supply and demand
factors are changing and how does it
work well it compares the volume and
Delta changes over a period of time you
know again real quick this is a Dax this
is I don't know what day this was the
8th two days ago
Wednesday one minute chart again not a
lot of signals but you know you had a
nice buy here well this is after the
cash close in the Dax so it's following
the US market you know there's you know
Dax is a decent Market to trade once the
Europe cash session Clos cuz at that
time it's sort of a slave to what the US
Market's doing and you know if the US
Market's moving in One Direction you can
generally get some nice nice Trends so
so here was a nice buy shot up here's
another buy it shot up here's another
buy kind of went down probably would
have stopped off before shooting up and
then he
was gives you a buy and it goes nowhere
in the next bar this is a minute chart
and then it just jumps right up here
then you get a sell and again it goes
lower so you know it just kills me
sometimes you know people don't want to
take
you know a minute to to shoot me an
email saying hey what uh what setting do
you recommend you know just just give me
give me my money back you know what
whatever um honestly I get a lot of more
positive emails than negative emails and
you know I'd rather deal with the
positive people than than the negative
people in the
world I mean there's always going to be
people that are unhappy you know I
worked with a guy and you he just
disliked me I don't want to say hated me
I'll just say disliked me
and I could literally walk into into
work and say um good morning good
morning you know to everybody and then I
say hi to him and he'll be upset oh you
said good morning to everybody else you
only say hi to me you know there's
people like that in this world and it
just uh you know one of the earliest
piece of career advices I was
given um was by this guy Larry
mulner who you he was the head of Dean
Witter futures
and you know a little bit of History you
know he's he was John
Henry's buddy back in you know back in
the 50s and 60s they were they they
really worked together and Larry molar
actually helped find you know a lot of
the money for uh John Henry to be
trading with but he gave me this advice
as you know there's going to people be
people that you get along with there's
going to be people you don't get along
with and no matter what you do you can't
please those people might as well spend
more time with the ones that you get
along with you know and and develop
those relationships cuz you know that's
where your your relationship is you
you're you're going to grow more as a
person when you're talking with people
that you get along with rather than
trying to fight people over things so
you know that's why I put these out
because you know even though I do get
Negative emails I I do get positive
emails from people and that you're very
appreciative of these videos that I that
I put out that's why I put them
out and you know I said a lot this
information I just put it out there and
you know I get emails from people saying
hey you know what I use this other IND
you know they don't use my orderflow
chart they use a different one and they
say you know they they spent thousands
of dollars on these other software and
they don't make sense and then they
watch my videos and it all makes sense
you know and they're very grateful and
you know at the end of the day that's
that's my goal is to help
people so you know these are the
settings that I use on my charts right
here um you know on my trading system
it's
3 400 100 you can see it here 3 400 400
and 100 I'll get into what these mean so
the period the look back is three the
ratio balance 1 and two is
400 and the max balance volume is 100
and you know let me explain what these
settings are is you know how far back to
analyze a setting is three is three bars
back a setting of 10 would be 10 bars
back so you know if you change the
setting
to three it's just going to you know use
its analysis over the last three bars
now you know with with order flow it's
very rare that I really look back you
know 10 bars 20 I'll say 10 bars you
know anything more than 25 bars um you
know in one of the other
indicators I use a setting of 50 which
you know takes into account where the
Market's been over the last 50 bars but
you know for this one where I'm trying
to pick up changes in supply and
demand I'm I'm really more interested in
What's Happening Now rather than what's
happening a bit later um you know in
those in that one other indicator that's
really the the only time I would really
look back over a wider period and part
of the reason for that other one is you
know it's more to filter out um some of
the fluctuations in the market but for
this one you know three is fine you know
you could try five I wouldn't probably
go over 10 but um you know I'm fine with
three fine with five and you know if you
want it if you don't want to use it you
just you could change this from True to
false the uh number four on you can
change it to false then you know you
won't be have to worry about the period
Then the ratio balance one and two is is
400 and what those numbers are it's a
ratio change from supply and demand or
demand to supply keep it at 400 which
means you know it's going to be 400%
so you know the change will be four
times as great and you could try 500 I
for a while I was using 500 I use 400
because you know that's what I'm most
comfortable with and you know even when
you're looking at imbalances in the
market you know Market imbalances on a
footprint
chart you know the standard that people
use for that is is 400% as well so it's
you know it's a it's a decent number I
said you can make it bigger and know if
you make it if you make it at say 900 or
a th000 you know that'd be nine times as
great or you know 10 times as great of
course you'll have a lot less
signals and I I don't know honestly I
haven't run the test on them to know if
it's going to be any more effective
maybe you know one of you guys will you
know find the time to do that I'm
extremely happy with 400 you for a while
I actually used 300 but um as well but
you know 400 I'm comfortable with and
you know it makes sense to me the max
balance
volume which is this one here Max
balance volume is you know this it's a
volume
number that you know goes into the
equation to
determine if there's you know being
shift in supply and demand all right you
know normally when a
market if you're familiar with the term
absorption right what's absorption you
know it's when the market sort of
contracts and you you trade around value
for a while because everyone's happy
trading um at a certain price you know
and you don't get much price movement
you know you're sort of trading in a
range but you know your value area is
pretty
tight U how to say it better um you know
you're not going to have necessarily big
changes in in Delta because buying and
selling will be about equal right when
you're in an area of absorption you know
buyers and sellers are evenly matched
and what this Max balance volume
measures you know it's measuring When
Buyers or sellers are roughly around
evenly matched I mean you could make it
bigger um you know I like setting of 100
I'm comfortable with it I find
setting you know if you go 500 obviously
you'll get a lot more a lot more signals
if you set it at 10 you'll get a lot
less signals but you know a 100 for me
is is is a number that actually works
with you know pretty much every contract
I've tried 50 before on thinner
contracts but you know there hasn't been
any major noticeable difference the
noticeable difference is when you get
into much uh much higher numbers
especially on thicker
markets and again you know if you're
trading us products trade during the US
hours ideally 7:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m.
although I did just show you a Dax which
is after the cash close in
Europe well some yeah no I think it was
all after the cash close let me see at
10:00 European cash closes around
10 um but again you know if so I
I but for us products you know it's
ideal to trade them during the US
hours um you know the Dax there's a lot
of ARB going on between the Dax and and
the e- minis but again you know for most
contracts outside of those times you
have less volume as the underlying cash
markets closed so the moves are based on
other unrelated fundamentals
you know so as you can see you know that
Dax trade those Dax trades you know the
market is really following what the S&P
are doing at that
time so again you know times to trade I
can't stress this enough that's why I
keep the slide in all my all my
presentations because you know people
either don't listen or don't care but be
careful trading around data releases or
announcements for example the
unemployment number or fed announcement
you know volume will dry up and you get
quick moves back and forth in One
Direction and sometimes in in seconds
you know you could have literally in 2
seconds you could have 10 bars print and
as a result you're going to get chopped
up or your head cut off if you're on the
wrong side of the market yeah if if
you've ever
traded and you tried sitting through
some of these numbers you you know
exactly what I mean you know it's one
thing to be paper trading during the
number and you know you suffer a loss
you don't really care but you know if if
you're trading real money and you're
sitting through a number and next thing
you know you know you got long snps and
all of a sudden it's it's sold off 10
points against you in a matter of
seconds by the time you go in to cover
it you know you're down eight points um
you know you'll be very upset and you
know you'll sit there and say why do I
trade but you know don't trade around
those time periods you know there's
nobody holding a gun to your head saying
you got to trade around an unemployment
number you got to trade during a Fed
announcement you don't okay so this just
better to sit out and and wait you know
part of being a successful Trader is
being in you know having the the
ammunition so to speak you know having
the funds to trade when the
opportunities occur and if you're you're
going to be taking a risk you know
during a a very volatile time then you
know there's going to be times it does
work out there's going to be times when
it doesn't work out the only difference
is during those times when it doesn't
work out you know you've it blew through
your stop and you know all of a sudden
taking it instead of taking a two-point
loss you're taking an eight-point loss
because of the volatility and the lack
of liquidity so it's just best to to you
know wait for when the Market's back to
normal and everything is proceeding as
planned so you know let's go take a look
at the settings I'm going to go over a
bunch of charts again for the month of
January and these settings are actually
all the same in this case you know it's
3 400
100 Now the default settings that come
with the software change them all you
got to do is you just click on the chart
open it up go into this thing here
change three put three there put 400 put
400 put 100 that's all you got to do
it'll take you less
than you know 20 seconds to do and just
save it save your
template so let's go run through a bunch
of charts from you know early January
first week of January to the first week
of February
okay so we'll start
here this is a uh one minute chart in
the Euro curreny 6E yeah and notice the
settings 400 400 3 and
100 let me just get this I'll make it
smaller so it's easier to
see okay so again you I'm going to show
you whatever I can show you again these
are us hour these charts are set
from 6:00 a.m. until 300
p.m. so let's see what we got this is
what day is this first one well this is
the second day is the four so this is
the 3rd January 3rd okay just you
know a little move up here you know
nothing here stopped you out maybe there
nothing little move lower again these
are very scrunched up you know this one
sideways now next day you know this a
nice move up here's a nice move up
here's a little bit of a move
down this one didn't work
out this one I should make that bigger
so it's easier to
see okay it didn't really work out this
one didn't work out you know this day
was not that great on a one minute chart
next day you get a nice move down here
get a nice move up nice nothing
here a little bit of something before
you get a Buy Signal it goes back
up this one didn't work
out um here's a nice little move
lower again a nice you know sell signal
kind of went up against it before
selling
off this one's a little bit close to the
close nonfarm payrolls again you know
you're not going to be necessarily
taking this trade I don't think think at
7:15 cuz you know you it's 7:15 you're
thinking you know if I got to hold it
for 15 minutes I got to run up into that
number and which is like a chain saw you
could see the volatility there wait for
the market to settle down and it did
later you know you got this sell here
this one didn't necessarily work out but
look at this came right back with this
nice sell here and you know say you
missed this trade again you got another
entry
here and look at that you're
talking around the 106 level down to
you know
10560 get a little buy there and the
sell here coming in after two EUR
currency you know be careful trading it
after uh after 2:00 Chicago time you
know the liquidity really dries up until
the Asian session especially on Friday
um you know everyone in New York's gone
home
already this one didn't work out then
there's a nice you know it went up then
came back down and then went back up
this one's a bit choppy this one failed
this one failed
little bit later little winner here nice
little winner here another long signal
there nice sell there buy here again you
this is iffy if I'd be looking to take
it it's right around the 2:00
close here's a down move up move down
move nice down move up
move that didn't work out this what did
this did this did well I don't know
that's kind of sideways probably getting
near your
stop yeah I I know some people will say
oh you see again these are Us hours
charts so it doesn't show the night
session but I'm sure there would be you
know there's some vendors out there will
say oh you see you could have sold it
here at 130 come in the next day look
where it's
trading you know it's 50 points
lower that just kills me you know for
for people that trade in day they're not
going to do that and who wants to sit up
all night long sweating out a position
when you know you got plenty of
opportunities during the day to sweat
out a
position um you know big money is made
overnight but you know you got to decide
what type of Trader you're going to be
then you know you're going to really
blow out your risk um your risk
parameters if you start holding
positions overnight you know especially
these
currencies you know if some Central Bank
somewhere does something you know it can
can move quite swiftly through you you
know just look at you know
what happened with the Swiss frank a few
years ago 2014 January you know it wiped
out nearly wiped out some Futures broker
uh foreign exchange
Brokers you know and all of a sudden you
know guys were getting these margin
calls when they didn't think they'd ever
get a margin
call so okay this one didn't work out
this one not really this one did this
one didn't this one did before it
failed here I don't know if I would have
stopped you out this one didn't really
work out
out again I'm not going to say oh you
could have bought it here right after
the close and hold it till the next day
and it's up there that's just not uh
prudent I don't know you if you're want
to stay up and manage it okay but I'm
not saying you would you would do it and
hold it this one kind of went sideways
these well this day my data was kind of
mixed up I
remember so I can't really Analyze That
Day
properly here it went down a little bit
up kind of sideways here's a buy that
didn't work
out this one kind of just goes sideways
here this one started moving
lower this one didn't work out this one
nice move up gradual slow move up
methodical then starts working its way
back down
again this one you kind of just sideways
in both here then you get another cell
signal here right ahead of this again
this is 2:00 that's why you sometimes
you see in the Euro
currencies um at 2:00 you see quite a
bit
of
activity okay so here's a buy worked out
here's a sell kind of nothing really
this one's sideways this one yeah that
one worked out I'd say this one it's
going one of these cup
formations started to work out then
moved against you this one didn't really
work out that's
already close to
3:00 this one's a little bit early 630
but it worked out this one no this one
no these kind of sideways this this one
failed that failed this one sort just
ran into all this chop up there I don't
know what I can't remember what happened
on the 20th I sto my head
that one didn't work
out okay oh here you got a nice smooth
lower coming to this buy it didn't work
out you got a sell here and did go down
this one would have stopped you out this
one it's nice little trade here it's a
nice little trade here it's a nice trade
going
up before it comes back down that one
didn't work
out made this little move up then you
get the cell signal then go sideways
this one not really this one not
really this one not really this one
these are just sideways a lot of these
trades
here okay that that's nice trade
there here it probably would have
stopped you out get this these Market
just just going sideways on you
there what do you got here you got a
nice move here nice little move there
yeah maybe break even nice little small
move there Sell
Here Sell here or this little buy here
this sell just sideways
here kind of
sideways sideways
there okay where are we March sry
February already
um maybe small loss
here B ke in here there's a loss here
here we sort of went up here you went
down this next one kind of lower
sideways to lower up down
up that's after 2
o'l the second this is a nice you know
I'm not saying you take this trade it's
right on the open you know generally I
start start my charts at
um six but you know sometimes I don't
actually get all the data coming in
until 8 for whatever reason sometimes I
I'm rushing to open up my my trading
system you know this been the last busy
couple of weeks I've been literally all
over the place and so that's why some
charts have missing a little bit of
periods or there's one or two days I
wasn't even trading but again I'm
showing you all these different charts
because I want you to see how it is how
how it looks on you know different
charts different time periods and
settings in this case though the
settings are all the same so this one so
you know again I don't think I would
have taken that here is a nice uh you
know here's a nice sell and it's just
under pressure all day again you just
get the confirm confirmation there to be
short and all the way down in here where
you start seeing some Buys so you know
that's a nice uh that's a nice that's a
nice day you only had to take one trade
now this is the non-farm payroll
day for uh Feb
again I wouldn't be taking any trades
right ahead of there sometimes I do but
uh most of the time I don't but this one
you know 8:00 around there you know the
market sort of quieted down you know
that's a nice trade right there this one
didn't work out then you get another buy
here and and look it's just straight up
there then you get some more signals
later this one didn't you know sort of
worked out then sort of came down then
you get some sells here you know when it
went lower this one again sort of the
same as what you had here started out
and then just fell off then you again
it's Friday afternoon already getting
into the close there even though it did
just sort of go sideways before turning
up so that's the uh one
minute chart I'll show you this this is
the eight range real quick again I'll
try to just blow through these so you
again it's I don't need to hold your
hand on it even you guys can see it and
you know decide for yourself if it's
good or not um
um okay so this day there was
nothing are some nice moves in here you
know some small swings in here this is
an eight range chart so you know
difference with eight you know with
range chart obviously in in minute based
charts is
because you know range based chart it's
the price rotating back and forth
whereas a minute chart is you know the
bar ends because it's 10:05 and then the
next bar starts at 10:06 so you know the
fluctuations are are different that's
why you know eight range and a minute
you know an eight range chart and a one
minute chart look a lot
different Al on an eight range reversal
chart it's going to give print nine
ticks because you got to go with that
extra tick to complete the chart so if
you see one bar so even if it moves one
bar you're already talking nine ticks
yeah but sometimes you get you know when
when the beauty of a range chart
sometimes you get these nice clean moves
like
this because the market is just moving
in One
Direction you know like here is a nice
move up you know this one didn't work
out but you know you should have been
alert to catch this first move here you
know people will say well this one
didn't work out it sucks well did you
catch this one no I didn't cuz I don't I
don't I don't trust it well when when
you start trusting how you're trading
you you'll be taking more
signals so here's just you know again
it's nice but anyway I'll just try and
run through these so you can
see I don't need to comment on
everything you're intelligent
okay this day here is two signals they
both failed okay there will be days that
no matter what you do you you just get
you take a loss I mean it's unfortunate
but those days happen you know but again
you just want to come back the next day
still have faith in what you're doing
and you know get the get some stuff you
know start covering it back here this
one didn't work out this one sort of did
a little bit this one give you something
again these are eight range charts and
eight range charts so you know one bars
is eight ticks nine
ticks you know and but if you're stuck
with it you know you could catch a nice
move here a nice move there and you know
you'd be covering back a lot of your
your losses pretty quick you know you're
not might not necessarily get it all
back in one
trade but you know stick with it and you
know you should be able to get it back
and again you know would you be willing
to take a couple small losses here to
catch this move
here some people don't they they don't
want they want every move like this
they're unwilling to take a couple of
small
losses you just got to decide you know
what kind of Trader are you
these are the ni days where it's just
one signal it's just all down after
that but those days are rare so this is
the non-farm pay well again I wouldn't
be trading here at 7:30 but 740 you know
that's fine you could take that trade
you know if not this one didn't work out
but then it came right back here with a
nice trade that worked out so even if
you said I gota wait till 8 o'clock to
take it and then you get a loser here
yeah if you stick with it a little bit
later you got a nice sell here so you
know it worked
out okay what next uh NQ I got NQ charts
here this one
here one minute chart in the
NQ I don't remember how this looked but
uh we'll take a look go through
it okay what do we got here this starts
on the 3rd of
January again the NQ is a contract you
really shouldn't be trading until the
cash open at 8:30 Chicago
time you know that's when the the nice
the the NASDAQ
opens and you can see how it it really
picks up activity after 8:30 you here
you got very small bars doing nothing
and you can see how it is after
afterwards so here's a nice sell I don't
need to explain
that again you know try and restrict
your NASDAQ trading to the cach after
8:30 when the act the the volume picks
up what do you got here yeah some little
sells that work the buys not really I
mean it's you depending on what your
profit targets are these didn't work
but again that's 7
7:30 you know
8:00 again it's just right ahead of the
cash I don't know You' taken it if you
did you would have been greatly
rewarded some small trades
there it's kind of mixed
okay so I didn't give a signal here some
people say oh it didn't tell me to buy
here it's terrible well sometimes
there's nothing in the order flow
necessarily given in way that you should
be trading
there you know some people think that
every high or low is going to be picked
in the order flow no it's not you know
sometimes the market just makes a
natural low or M natural high
here's nice little move this one didn't
work here's a nice little move here's a
nice little move here's a nice little
move some nice little
moves a little bit let's go
sideways again you some nice nice
nice this is nice
after 8:30 you got sell didn't work out
sell didn't work out then you buy then
work out again you maybe he took a
couple small losses in here but you if
you stuck with it you're
rewarded look at
[Music]
that know nice move up nice move down
didn't work out there but you know this
one gave you something this one you know
maybe you scratched maybe you lost a
tick or
two you know the scaling on this these
look small
but you really got to should expand it
but if I did then it' be like very
difficult to go through all these very
quickly this stay is kind of
mixed you here's some nice little
swings some nice moves there yeah this
one failed but you know you got a nice
winter there you got some nice little
swings
here
again there's just that's a nice like
cascading move there but it's a little
bit close to the close I don't know if
I'd be interested in it there's a nice
move up
nothing really nothing
really nice this one didn't work out it
started too but then it failed I don't
know maybe you could have if you traded
it correctly maybe you got something out
of it then you know these are just all
in your favor this one here didn't work
out and nonfarm payrolls
here you know again it's setting you up
with some decent trading opportunities
some decent entries in
here so what is that okay so we go to
the
uh NASDAQ 8 range chart
again all these settings it's 3 400
100 it's all the
same not using any special curve fitted
numbers you know that oh this Market you
got to look at this one or this Market
it's got to be set to there no these are
the same numbers you know in this case
it's dealing with ratios so it's uh it's
fine to be this around the same
so again you know here's some nice
little cells here
down that one just went sideways that
went
lower try and blow through some of these
charts a lot
quicker this one didn't work out you
know usually I don't necessarily talk
about the ones that worked I just show
you the ones that didn't work is what
I'm more concerned with CU I don't want
you thinking that every trade you're
going to take is going to be a winner no
but you can see the types of winners and
the types of losers that you have
I just want to talk about this real
quick you
know for some people you know it's
probably prudent for them to to Trail
their stops you know to at least lock in
some profits and you know this is a
perfect type of indicator that you can
do that on you get these moves to go up
then they start turning on you again you
know moves that go up start turning on
you again but if you're trailing your
stop at least you know you're getting
out somewhere up here rather than down
in
here that's nice right there right
this one failed this one failed this
one nice winner gets back what you just
lost over those last couple
trades comes back with s of a loser and
a
loser this one's kind of mixed
get what you will out of
that it's a nice one that's a nice
one
nothing nice
[Music]
move nice little little moves
there that one didn't work out this one
yeah probably
not it's a nice move
there again this a little something
here and a nice move here
okay so that's
the mini NASDAQ 8 range chart now let's
go to a mini
da one minute
chart again same settings 3 100 400
me die like it's a nice contract to
trade so this is the day Market's just
dropping off it's giving you a buy Here
a failed a buy here that failed you know
you know that it's failing pretty quick
so that's the nice thing I
guess then here's a buy that started to
work out then you get a nice sell signal
here
you so hopefully on at least on this
trade you could have made back whatever
you lost on those previous trades you
know but again you know people oh look
uh the market just dropped like this
didn't give me a sell signal well there
was no sell signal to give
you that's a nice one but
still these are some nice gradual moves
here
this Market's really going
sideways that one didn't work
out
oops some failures there kind of a
failure there then it work there nice
trade there so again you know you got to
stick with it you know if if you just
give up oh I had a loss here I had a
loss here I had a loss here I give up
I'll sit it out don't sit it
out you know because if you sit it out
what you're going to do is you're going
to miss this trade it's okay I said I'll
wait for her to start producing winners
again and that's then you're going to
miss these two trades here to get back
everything you just lost I mean sure I I
understand the logic that oh well if I
don't sit out I could take more losses
well if you're not willing to take the
risk you shouldn't be
trading you know it's like the baseball
player gets up to the major
leagues and he just sits up there with
the bat on his shoulder when it's time
you know when he's at the plate and you
know the manager just comes back says
you you got to swing you know you'll
never stay in the majors unless you take
swings
[Music]
okay some of the small winners
there nice gradual move up nice gradual
move
down
whoops again I'm trying to show you as
much as I
can you know
show you stuff like this where it
doesn't really sort of spin your wheels
cuz you got to see that you got to
understand
that again you can you sit through
this chop in
here this one going
sideways and then you know you're just
sitting there Wai laying in wait for
this move from um you know 19840 down to
7 19790 that's a 50 point move right
there you know then you get some nice
little moves here as
well so sure you had a couple of losers
but then you had some very nice
winners I'm not even going to say sell
it here and hold it through that big
drop but
uh I don't want to get into
that in here you got some nice solid
trades here
s go through a little bit faster so you
can see some of these trades I don't
want to keep you guys here too long but
again I want you to see how it performs
over
time and I think this is the best way to
do it
looks better when you blow it up expand
the chart but
still so you're just looking at a chart
that looks like is going sideways
doesn't look as
nice again some nice solid moves here
I don't even know how that's got turn
out but over the next this is when the
cash opens here this is before cash this
is after cash get a nice little move
there I I don't know if you really would
have got much out of this move
honestly You' have to be very fast it's
a one minute chart so you can can act
responsibly but back there is the cash
um non-farm pay
rolles anyway that's the one minute
chart uh let me see if I got a a range
chart in here I'm sure I
do again eight range mini da same
settings 3 100
400 okay um let me jump ahead to the E
mini one minute chart want to see what
we
got again it's still the same
settings
um 3 100
400 now e minis it's an interesting
contract cuz it is
liquid yeah it's a viable contract you
can trade you know from European open I
mean the volume that it puts in during
the European session is you know a lot
of contracts would like to have that
during the during their main session
actually but uh but anyway let's see
what we got in here with this setting
the same setting I mean you again these
settings are not set in stone you could
always adjust
them this is a more liquid contract so
you know maybe you might want to adjust
that uh this setting here this one the
100 the max balance volume you know
maybe you could blow it out to uh try
200 you know give it a try give it with
uh you know some different numbers um
again you know these numbers are not set
in stone but if if you know if it's not
giving you any signals you it's
something that depends on the volume and
you know if the Market's puts in lots of
numbers you if it's a thick Market when
I say puts in lots of numbers what I
mean is if it's got you know if it
trades a lot of volume and if you're
using a small volume number like 100 on
the e- minis you know maybe it won't
give you that many
signals and I'm just blow looking
through it here I don't see any so far
this is a this is already a few
days I know there's some I saw some on
on some chart but I mean I know this is
you know in the e- minis you know when
you're looking at a volume of 100 that's
nothing you know on a one minute chart
some of these bars I know got volumes of
8,000 10,000 so it's going to be very
very
rare let me just uh scrunch it up a bit
more see if there's anything nothing yet
really
yeah so there's nothing I mean volume of
a bar the volume of 100 is very small
for an e- mini 1 minute chart so maybe
on that you know you could probably blow
it out to you know a couple hundred or
you know 500 even try it you know part
of being a Trader is finding what works
for you what you're comfortable with and
you know going with it I mean don't
think that you know even though you know
Tony Robbins you know the great
motivational speaker
says go find out what's you know find
someone successful and see what they're
doing and copy it well you know in in
certain businesses yeah you can do that
you know like say uh internet marketing
or making money online or bodybuilding
you you can copy it almost exactly but
you know with trading you know there
there's a bit of a personal Journey you
got to go
through find what works for you that
you're comfortable with in in trading
it's not just copy exactly 100% what I'm
doing and you know you're guaranteed to
make money no you know no one's going to
be able to copy 100% cuz you don't
there's things that I have locked up in
the back of my head I don't even know
they're there but you know when the
situation arises you know it comes to
the front and unless you know there's a
way to suck everything out of my brain
you're not going to know everything that
I know and again I'm not trying to say
that you know in a bra braggy way or
anything I'm just saying you know
there's things that I don't even know
that I remember you know um kind of
doesn't make sense but uh I think you'll
understand what I mean you know you
can't copy somebody 100% you know on
everything you know just like cooking
you know um you you you work with a
brilliant you know Michelin star
Chef doesn't necessarily going to mean
you know you're going to be a five star
Chef as well you know there's things
that he knows about how to cook you know
how to cut a fish a certain way or you
know how to
you know how to prepare something that
you know sometimes it just doesn't get
translated over to you even if you've
been working for him for 20 years so
anyway this is the e- mini 5 range chart
now now you see a bit different you know
now you're seeing signals whereas on the
one minute chart you
didn't some of these work some don't but
you know it's a starting point you know
again you know are you willing to take a
small loss here catch this nice trade
here again you know maybe 100 is a bit
too fine a small a number you should
probably maybe blow it out to a bigger
number but again it's something that you
can you can test you know when I get
time I'll test it so you know the one
minute chart there wasn't that
uh that
much number so that was a five rang it
goes look at the fiveyear real
quick one minute
chart so this will be the last chart
that I'll go
over again you know part of being a good
Trader successful Trader is doing the
work yourself research yourself um you
know we all like to have things handed
to us I mean I know I like to
on certain topics but you know at the
end of the day you still got to put in
work you still got to put in effort you
know things don't always come
easily so here's a fiveyear
chart roll it up again you know
getting so you know here's some nice
trades here one two
three I think earlier people say oh you
didn't scroll back to the beginning okay
so yeah I didn't go all the way back
here but still it's a nice move up nice
move down nice move
down some nice trades there some nice
trades here this
one nice move up nice move down sideways
then down nice move
down a bit difficult in there but you
could have got something I think nonf
fireing payrolls you know for this
Market the 5 years you see how volatile
it is so you know be careful if you're
trading around that time you know if
you're getting into a trade here
probably don't want to take it you even
though you get a nice a nice uh set up
just wait for something when it calms
down here gives you a little something
here gives you a little
something looks a little better here
nice moves here nice moves there nice
moves there nice move
there you know this is a market if you
could scalp a few ticks that's great you
know you can be in and out in and out
margin a couple hundred bucks and you
could trade five lots and make a few
ticks although a tick one tick is only
like seven bucks
seven
7.81
$781 so you know it's questionable
whether you if you're trading 10 Lots
you know that's 78 bucks a
tick you know you make three ticks
it's 200 bucks right there and you're
getting some nice
signals yeah I'm not advocating that you
do I don't want someone go oh you told
me to do that no I'm just giving you
options that you can do it you know it's
a people always talk about oh you know
I'm paper trading I'm paper trading why
you know there's these contracts out
there they got low margin the experience
you're going to get from paper trading
versus trading with real money
is not even comparable you know when
there's when you have skin in the game
so to speak when you have money on the
line your decision- making process is
completely different you know you'll be
thinking differently so when you're
paper trading you don't necessarily get
out when you should get out you know you
hold positions longer and you take
stupider trades well I don't say that
but you know sometimes when you're paper
trading you think a just that looks
bored I'll take it but if you're trading
real money you might not take it so it's
night and day and you could open
accounts for a few thousand dollars and
you know just trade one lot no one says
you got to trade 10 Lots right away if
you can't make money with the trading
one Lots you're sure as hecking going to
make money trading 10
Lots nice moves
here oh people send me an email oh I
bought here and then it sold off you
suck
whatever did then I'll say did you take
this trade no I didn't cuz I lost on
that trade well should have a stop in
place he said you could only only tell
people certain
things again I'm not complaining but you
know what I mean you know people come to
me they want to learn but they don't
want to actually
put into practice what I teach them um I
mean know whatever uh and people come to
me wanting to learn certain things and
you know again I I teach them what I you
know what I think they want to learn and
what I think is useful to
them again you know these are some nice
moves here this one doesn't work out
nice move up this one nice move
down this one doesn't work
out this one does this one doesn't this
is kind of a scratch in there maybe you
could have got something here this one
nothing really that's 230 already
it's a nice
one nice downward action you know all
cells
there sell here this one didn't work out
this one sideways
sideways okay I'm not going to talk
about this cuz it's right ahead of the
close this is just right after the you
know again it's 6:30 in the morning I
don't know if I'd take it 7 yeah I don't
know
maybe definitely not here but here maybe
I'd be interested but didn't work out
but came back with the sell didn't work
out but it came back with the buy that
give you a little bit of something then
this one definitely gave you
something this one didn't really work
out this one
well again I don't say oh yeah you would
bought it here and sold it up here
honestly I would have taken this one
probably up to somewhere in here start
coming down I would have got out I'm not
saying I'd take that definitely I I
would love to but i' would love to have
gotten a buy a little bit closer in here
like here rather than down here cuz you
know it goes up this a minute chart I'm
not looking to hold it for over an hour
on a minute chart even unless it's
really literally straight up
whoops thing there there's a cell here
went
down nice little Cell nice little
cell this one failed on you pretty quick
so why you got to have a stop in there
could have got something back there
hopefully and definitely if you didn't
cover back what you lost here you
definitely could have covered it back
there again you got to have stops in you
don't want to be buying it here taking
it all the way up there then getting out
down here Trail your stop Trail your
stop at a
minimum there's a nice trade Follow by a
nice trade this one didn't work
out again this is right on the close
that's right on the
open sideways that one stop you
out
sideways nonfarm payrolls again you
you're not going to be taking this trade
because you know you could be looking at
this and you
know so after the market calms down a
nice Buy Here Sell you not really work
out this buy did this buy
did you know these sells worked out this
buy not really
sideways these are already Friday
afternoon 2 o' not interested
so again you know these are the settings
you try and keep it during Us
hours and I went through enough markets
for you guys to see this indicator in
action make the decision yourself if if
you think it's useful to you and
something you could add to your trading
you know I do think it's a great tool
and I do think it's underutilized and
misunderstood by people out there but by
adding it to your trading Arsenal you
know it's going to give you some trades
honestly you know sometimes it's a
numbers game you know you got to be in
the market you got to have something
give when your signals to
trade otherwise you know you're you're
never going to take a trade but it's
it's a good starting point to you know
get your feet wet with order flow and
understanding supply and demand shifts
in supply and demand so thanks for
watching this and you know hope to see
you on the inside bye-bye